on passe aux sports à présent nous
allons parler des jeux paralympiques
les jeux paralympiques ont débuté le 29
août ils s'achèveront le 2 septembre la
délégation française se porte bien et
même une semaine de plus ce sera le 9
septembre je vois régis harel qui est
conviée sur ce plateau qui va nous
parler dans un instant effectivement
c'est le 9 septembre j'ai oublié une
semaine sur une manifestation qui est
déjà pas très médiatisé c'est pas
forcément très bien être des
représentants yvelinois y participent
saint quentinois vous allez le voir dans
un instant pour témoigner sur ce plateau
régis a donc bon soir vous avez
participé au giro par le passé will
happen athènes en 2004 c'était en tennis
fauteuil vous allez nous dire un petit
peu ce que ça représente pour pour un
athlète également sur ce plateau jean
loup le plat président du cnosc le
comité départemental olympique et
christine le faire bonsoir à vous
bonsoir à tous les deux vous êtes de le
à saint-quentin l'entente athlétique de
saint quentin en yvelines et vous avez
entraîné notamment nantenin keita vous
l'entraîné nantenin keita athlètes qui
va courir ce soir si vous me suivez en
direct il est 18h30 et vers 20h
l'antennagate have a participé au 400 m
à la finale du 400 m est exactement et
dans quel état d'esprit elle est ce que
vous l'avez eue aujourd'hui alors pas
moi mon époux avec qui je partage le
groupe qui s'en occupe plus
particulièrement elle est remonté comme
une pendule est-ce que vous pensez que
la bonne chance justement on va
peut-être cité son palmarès aussi mais
là déjà sur cette course là sur cette
finale la médaille d'or sera
probablement très difficile à obtenir
mais je pense qu'elle a une bonne chance
d'être sur le podium puisque son
palmarès ni championne paralympique du
200 m à pékin 2008 médaille de bronze du
400 m ça c'était aussi en p qu'à pékin
championne du monde du 200 m et 400 m en
2006 vice-champion du monde du 100 m
aussi et j'en oublie encore vice
championne du monde 400 mètres dès 2002
voilà elle a connu
une année très difficile l'an passé avec
une grosse blessure elle s'en remet elle
est enfin de enfin de soins donc si elle
arrive à monter sur le podium ce sera
déjà une très belle récompense par
rapport à ces galères de la mutation les
athlètes illinois sont présents les
athlètes saint quentinois également on
peut citer la présence en ce moment du
côté de londres de florence irait aux
grosses gossio en tennis de table
également de frédéric quatre anneaux et
nicolas taillefer c'est un tennis
fauteuil comme vous régis à lille sont
d'ailleurs du même club de saint quentin
en yvelines vous leur avez parlé vous
avez échangé avant leur nom là où je les
laisse dans leur bulle ils sont pour
l'instant donc ça se passe très très
bien couru en simple ils ont passé lors
de tours donc ils sont et au troisième
tour et en double ils sont en quarts de
finale donc pour eux ça tout roule pour
l'instant qu'est ce que ça représente
justement pour un athlète en situation
de handicap de participer à ces jeux
paralympiques ça la même valeur même si
la question est un peu bête mais est-ce
que ça a la même valeur pouvoir
d'athlètes valides exactement en fait
les jeux olympiques c'est
l'aboutissement fait d'une carrière
sportif quand on arrive aux jeux sur les
jeux olympiques ou les jeux
paralympiques sais c'est le summum pour
pour tout athlète de pouvoir participer
à ces jeux c'est c'est l'épreuve ultime
comment vous l'avez vécu vous quand vous
avez participé moi j'ai vécu ça
pleinement en fait déjà
quand on rentre pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture sur le stade déjà c'est
grandiose c'est alors moi j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir capter ma famille
vraiment de les voir là le le coeur se
met à battre un peu plus et puis la
flamme olympique eux c'est pisser
l'ambiance en fête qui règne lors de ces
jeux c'est
là il ya plus de problème de religion
puis problème de langue plus rien c'est
on vient tous pour un même but un but
sportif et puis c'est c'est exceptionnel
mais est ce qu'il ya un sentiment aussi
différent par rapport aux athlètes
valides de se dire aussi c'est que c'est
un sentiment de revanche peut-être un
petit peu de se dire on peut se dépasser
on peut atteindre ce niveau d'excellence
aussi à la je pense pas qu'ils aient un
seul un sentiment de revanche en fait
c'est vraiment un sentiment
d'aboutissement pour pour le sport qu'on
pratique c'est pas c'était beaucoup de
préparation vous et c'est beaucoup
préparé pour partir en 2004 du jeu il
faut je préparais ces quatre ans elle
avance donc là actuellement ceux qui ont
un reer où il commence à se préparer
maintenant on voit des images vous avez
suivi à l'époque avant même 2004 on vous
voit travailler justement un petit peu
et là c'était au moment du départ ce
tournoi l'un du départ en deuxième je
lis chevelure rouge avant le départ mais
j'avais encore un peu plus de cheveux
comment comment se portent justement le
sport le handisport dans le département
des yvelines mais je pense qu'ils se
portent bien parce qu'il ya quand même
pas mal d'athlètes représentatif non
t'inquiète été cité mais il y en a
d'autres on les suit de près on
s'efforce de les associer à toutes nos
manifestations
mais je crois qu'il ya un bon potentiel
de sportifs
de handicap puisque c'est comme ça qu'on
dit sur le département il ya des quand
même quelques quelques stars si je peux
utiliser l'expression en quoi est-ce que
ça se développe parce que ça progresse
aussi parce que là il ya forcément un
focus qui ai fait pendant les jeux mais
oui je crois parce que que ce qu'il se
fait de sport handicap ou de sport
adapté comme on dit je pense que ces
comités se structure et se réunissent
ils travaillent ensemble ils travaillent
ensemble c'est que les grandes
fédérations je pourrais citer bien sûr
la fédération de l'adjectif la
fédération de tennis la fédération
d'aviron il constitue un pool commun ne
serait ce que pour s'entraîner se
préparer à organiser je trouve que ça
c'est une bonne chose il ya quand même
des grandes fédérations des moyens a les
moyens il y en aura jamais assez et vous
le savez bien mais oui quand même des
moyens oui parce que c'est difficile
justement mais beaucoup moins que dans
sports olympiques traditionnels
justement comment ça se passe pour se
préparer pour travailler au quotidien
justement avec des athlètes comme avec
non seulement keita par exemple je pense
que c'est très particulier en fonction
du handicap de l'athlète n'en tenez
déficientes visuelles donc
lassé de brasser de gens mais le reste
du corps qui fonctionne comme invalide
donc elle s'entraîne on va dire un peu
comme invalide après il ya des
adaptations liées à son handicap à avoir
mais je crois que les ce genre de
sportifs là a une faculté d'adaptation
qui est au delà de ce que valide peut
imaginer nous en entonnant elle est
capable de faire du relais donc elle est
capable de percevoir l'arrivée d'un
partenaire sans pouvoir visualiser une
marque donc et tout un système de codes
de communication qui se met en place
avec les partenaires elle est très
bagarreuse parce que je pense que ça
monsieur le confirmera mais je pense que
les athlètes handicapés ont de toute
façon envie de se comporter de la même
façon que les valides et qu'on voit chez
eux le sportif et non pas le handicap et
je pense que c'est ça ce sont des
sportifs de haut niveau
antonin comme les autres s'entraînent
énormément font les efforts qu'il faut
sur le plan diététique de l'hygiène de
vie du sommeil etc et c'est tout à fait
normal de les voir avec le même
enthousiasme que les valides se rendre
aux jeux paralympiques et c'est tout à
fait dommageable de ne pas pouvoir en
avoir une couverture médiatique et on va
en parler à la hauteur est ce que c'est
une frustration justement pour les
sportifs de voir que c'est pas forcément
couvert même si cette année tv8 mont
blanc de chaînes régionales qui va
diffuser les soixante dix sept heures de
programmes mais ce n'est qu'un début
c'est assez peu finalement oui mais
heureusement qu'ils sont là parce que
j'ai entendus lundi sur france inter
donc le président de france 2 france 3
qui qui parlait qui faisait qu'il avait
fait un effort je pense connaître
spécifique qui était prévu et finalement
il ya des comédiens qui est gérée en
place rien que le mot et
ça devrait pas être ça devrait pas être
un effort ça devrait être
cédée sportif c'est tout avant tout
c'est bon il est ils pratiquent pas le
mail le sport il pratiquer différemment
mais c'est des sportifs est ce que le
public aussi est demandeur le public est
demandeur et cfi seulement de voir en
fait toutes les a priori si vous
regardez sur les images que vous voyez
les tribunes sont pleines donc c'est que
le public est demandeur qui a vendu tous
les billets 2 millions ont été vendus il
ya également l'ombre qui espère donc
attendre un total de 2,5 millions de
billets même le vraiment de remplir au
maximum les stades à pékin s'était 1,8
million dont il est effectivement
surtout celle de progression mais j'en
viens à la question de la formation de
l'accompagnement parce que effectivement
ça dépend du handicap les structures
coup de plus ou moins cher c'est vrai
que pour faire du tennis fauteuil il
faut aussi pouvoir acheter le fauteuil
mais ça c'est quelque chose qui coûte
cher est ce qu'il ya des aides pour ça
des fédérations aide alors vu comment ça
s'est passé par exemple ben là nous ont
été beaucoup aidé par le conseil général
des yvelines qui nous aider pour parce
qu'on a le comité départemental des
yvelines qui qui fait de l'achat de
matériel qui aide à l'achat de matériel
mais après pour la saison elle même
gérant général c'est des sponsors privés
parce que les collectivités
territoriales ne peuvent pas ne pas
comment subvenir à sa ccd budget qui
sont qui sont relativement importants
donc après ben suivant chaque personne y
en a qui vont avoir plus ou moins de
chance on appris le facteur financier
est un facteur important en fait il faut
des centres nerfs aussi pour s'occuper
s'est imposée parce que je vois deux
formés spécifiquement par exemple pour
d'antonin keïta vous qui l'entraîné ils
n'ont je pense que dans l'activité que
pratique n'en tenait en athlétisme
il n'a pas une formation particulière si
ce n'est mais je dirais que c'est un peu
pareil pour les valides de s'adapter ben
petit peu au comportement à la mentalité
au moment un petit peu de désarroi que
les connell que connaissent tous les
sportifs de haut niveau donc ya pas une
formation particulière par contre il
faut savoir effectivement prendre en
compte l'athlète dans sa totalité et le
handicap fait partie de la totalité de
l'athlète donc il faut le prendre en
compte le plan au niveau du
développement justement du du sport en
situation de handicap qu'est ce qui est
fait les coûts de leur comité
départemental comme envoyer un comité
départemental
audi sport giffard il connaît forcément
donc c'est structuré mais je crois là où
il y aurait vraiment un effort à faire
je crois que c'est la règle a observé à
faire venir c'est que les non valides ou
les personnes souffrant d'un handicap
puissent entraîner en même temps qu ils
éveillent des deux plus en plus je crois
qu'un effort qui est fait par les
comités sportifs départementaux
alors évidemment il ya des limites quand
aux possibilités mais je crois que si on
arrive à faire ça ça commence on
aboutira au but recherché est déjà une
médaille pour les athlètes français et
cinq en or 9 en argent et en bronze
d'ailleurs on a pu le regarder il ya
peut-on vous parliez des médias
s'offrant deux pieds quand même constat
qu'après une pétition de 15000
signatures 50 minutes d'antenne à partir
de 17 heures l'après midi et c'est
effectivement encore à développer mais
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau pour
pour témoigner on souhaite bonne chance
un entonnoir keita et puis aux athlètes
mais maintenant qui va courir ce soir
maintenant à peu près deux heures même
pas dans une heure une heure si vous
nous suivez en direct et sera présent
sur le 400 m elle est engagée sur eux il
est engagé sur le 100 mètres qu'elle
courra mercredi très bien reviendrai sur
ce plateau en tout cas on vous donnera
les résultats merci à vous